I'm at 78 7 you know and my 1 6 right
clear talent
qf 7 8 7 9 landed after more than 19
hours in the air if as the airline plans
New York Sydney becomes a regular route
it will be the world's longest edge old
service this test flight had taken off
with more than a hundred tons of fuel on
board were six pilots but just 50
passengers they encouraged us to get up
and exercise in the back so we all did
like together and then they just kept
the lights on really really bright and
then they shut the light
Qantas airlines describe this as a
research flight one where passengers and
crew were monitored for almost a full
day and a full night in the air so there
was urine collection on board which was
completed all throughout the flight
we're wearing a number of sensors
passengers too were tested but for them
it was hardly a typical experience
everyone on this flight had a seat in
business with a flatbed so although they
were encouraged to move around and spend
parts of the flight sitting in the
economy section no one had to endure
being squeezed into the middle of an
economy row for almost 20 hours was this
really primarily a scientific experiment
or about publicity a marketing exercise
it was a science research flight I mean
the whole idea and the concept came from
these guys who said we need to do this
we want to see that this does work and
then we thought we could do something
with passengers at the same time it's
looking at the pilots and the cabin crew
and then we thought well since we are
doing it we know this a lot going to be
a lot of worldwide interest I think
we've been overwhelmed with the
worldwide interest the aircraft that ran
this flight a Boeing 787 wouldn't if
full have been able to make the 16
thousand kilometer journey regular
services await a new plane either the
triple 7x promised by Boeing or a
modified a 350 made by Airbus commercial
services also need regulatory approval
and a new deal over working condition
between Qantas and its pilots union but
if ultra long-haul flights start New
Yorker Sydney won't be the longest for
long London Sydney is also planned there
will be a test flight over that fruit
next month Andrew Thomas al Jazeera
Sydney